where can I find a crib crib crib crib
crib crib okay you just want to explain
what's happening right now
I'm trying to think of what object I
want to use as the experiment to see if
my phone is listening to me
[Music]
I put my phone outside of the broom the
object has to be so specific but so
unrelated to me that there is no
possible way that this ad would be
suggested to me aside from my phone
listening to me and giving me an ad I
cannot type it on my phone can't search
for it that's sound like such a psycho
kid related stuff like a crib oh I'm
never buying anything for a kid I
haven't been looking and I don't plan on
look that's a good I thought a lot I
think it's good is it clear
all right
[Music]
so because this is science and we want
to make this a fair experiment I'm going
to set some parameters for myself about
how this is conducted for the next week
everyday I'm going to say the word crib
50 times I think that's gonna be a fair
assessment to see if my phone is
listening to me
crib crib crib does anyone know where I
can buy like a baby's crib taking a walk
and go meet my wife for lunch and I
figured I'd squeeze a couple cribs in
crib crib crib crib crib just eating
some pizza crib crib where do you think
I buy a crib I keep getting excited
because this will be so crazy
if I'm on my phone one day and I see an
ad for a crib I wonder if my phone is
listening to me does anyone know where I
can get a crib I'm gonna be honest it
feels a little weird to sit in my
apartment just saying the word crib over
and over again
I hope my neighbors aren't listening I'm
about to go to sleep but I thought I
should get some cribs in the crib crib
crib can you hear me I phone it's day 2
just left the gym it's a disgusting
morning here in New York perfect time to
squeeze in some cribs can anyone hear me
I'd like to buy a baby's crib of all the
words I could have picked to be saying
over and over again crib is a weird one
crib crib crib crib Chelsea do you know
where I'd be able to buy a baby's crib
what are you gonna use that crib for how
do you pronounce it crib crib crib okay
crib crib babies crib crib for a baby
crib finally at the gym crib clean
I don't know I'm losing faith in this
experiment I think I'm actually getting
scared that I'm gonna be on Facebook or
Instagram or Twitter and there is gonna
be a crib advertisement I'm just gonna
miss it completely and then it's all
gonna be for nothing
I don't know guys I've just been
cribbing away all day every day I've
been really trying to pay attention to
the ads that are on my social media and
so far only seen Dick's Sporting Goods
there was a movie advertisement Glade
the air freshener like a grocery
delivery service and Volkswagen none of
which are [ __ ] based not even remotely
baby oriented my ability to say crib
into my phone 50 times while it's not
doing anything is dwindling nonetheless
I really want to see the south through
the end of the week because science
trip
[Music]
the end of the week the last day of the
experiment I'm starting to think this
was a gigantic waste of my time I
haven't seen anything on any social
media platform that is a suggested ad
for cribs thought somebody wasn't
listening to me if you're still
listening to me you're making me look
like an idiot
[Music]
you're not listening you have no idea
how badly I wanted to make this work
just by typing a little crib into my
phone just to see if something would
happen but this is an experiment and I
wouldn't do that to you guys okay so
it's day whatever I don't know what day
it is in this experiment but I've had a
thought
whoever's listening to me and my phone
is dead set on making me look like an
absolute [ __ ] so I think I'm gonna try
some other tactics to get crib as a
suggested ad in my social media son of a
[ __ ] it's in my phone now someone
texted me crib word must have gotten out
about this experiment I'm doing so I
don't know maybe this will help all
right here's the deal maybe my phone is
listening to me maybe it isn't I don't
know I haven't seen any evidence of it
so I put a little search into Google
Maps not looking for a crib but for a
Babies R Us they've got cribs so I don't
know if my food is gonna track me to the
store and then suggest something for me
but I've got some shopping to do
so look like gates not really cribs
little did I know I'm on the wrong floor
gotta go to level 3 for the cribs
something weird is going on I'd get up
here half the room is empty crib liners
I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here so I
just left Babies R Us and I'm not sure
whether I should laugh or chuckle or
freak out there was not a single crib in
the entire place literally everything
but cribs I know my phone is listening
to me guys you gotta believe me my phone
is listening to me crib crib crib crib
crib I've actually thought about why
it's not coming up on my phone I don't
think I've been saying crimp loud enough
crab crab crab get me a goddamn crab
[ __ ] do you think I'm proud of the way
I've been acting
you shouldn't be it's embarrassing now
the time has come to do the unthinkable
so now it's your move iPhone
listen up everybody this is the last day
of the experiment I can't do this
anymore if I get to the office and
there's not a suggested ad for cribs in
my social media we're done we're done
that's it guys it's the end of like well
over two weeks of just rambling crib
into my phone went through my suggested
ads again it's coca-cola its ziploc
Dannon yogurt I really thought this was
going to work I wanted it to work
the more I think about it though in
reality it's probably a good thing this
didn't work so in general does it mean
your phone is or isn't listening to you
I still don't know that's not for me to
say in terms of cribs no it is not
listening to me
[Music]
[Music]